today i'm going to be speaking with
naomi klein who is senior correspondent
at the intercept and also
author of how to change everything naomi
great to have you on today
happy to be with you i've been engaging
in this conversation with many in my
audience
about how we sort of make progress on a
lot of
of different issues that come down to
what people know and what people believe
certainly climate change would be on
that list at a more micro level you know
even beliefs about what happened in the
november of 2020 election would
count uh beliefs about how vaccines work
beliefs about
the the messages we get from the cdc and
others and
i believe that there's really no simple
fix here
i think that this is probably a
multi-generational project
folks have been sort of indoctrinated
into many of the orthodoxies that now
plague us
starting i would argue going back to the
reagan era
with stories of welfare queens and and
and so on and so forth
is i'm curious as to the reason uh for
for sort of um writing this book to be
accessible to younger readers is it at
least partially an acknowledgement of of
the the
the battle we're up against here that
will be quite a long battle
uh that's an interesting question um
you know i didn't think about it in that
way of like get em while they're young
i i i really wrote the book directed
at at young readers because this book is
it's my first book that is
uh um for young readers it's it's really
geared towards like
um middle school and and early high
school
and it's really because this is where
the energy of the climate movement is
right
now i you know i was on the board of
350.org
for a decade and was part of
kicking off the fossil fuel divestment
movement which was very much university
age
students and and and
those you know university age students
are still involved in all kinds of
activism as you know
but the energy of the climate movement
is now coming from
younger than that it's it's like greta
it's the greta generation
um and so and so that's why
i wanted to write a book for this kind
of i see a real generational shift and i
wanted to
arm those young people with the facts
and figures
to um you know to to to make them better
activists and
and to keep them in this in the struggle
for the long term
yeah you seem to go at what are frequent
misconceptions among
adults i mean i think what's interesting
is that the issues you're addressing
aren't particularly different because
the audience
is younger it's just eventually folks
with misunderstandings get older and
then they become adults with a lot of
a lot of the same misunderstandings as
an example you go at this idea of
climate change isn't just it's warmer
everywhere all the time
we're talking about there there could be
a warming over all of the oceans with
erratically hot
and cold weather the way we've seen in
texas and in other places
the issues seem to be quite similar as
if you were addressing an
adult audience yeah look the information
in this book is
not um substantively different
than than the information in books i've
written for
for older readers um it's
not dumbed down it's just kind of
simplified and a lot of people have told
me that they
think that the book would be actually
suitable for adults that they know
which may well be true and i'm not going
to comment on that i mean because we
didn't dumb it down we just kind of
pared it down
simplified it and the fact is you know
the first book i wrote about climate
change this changes everything
has 70 pages of endnotes i mean it's
really like um it's just very backed up
and it's really about bringing the
receipts
and proving and re-proving because when
that book was published in 2014
making the argument that it's sort of
the core drivers of capitalism and
neoliberal the neoliberal project that
are at the root of why we failed
to address this crisis was treated as a
really really radical
idea and so i really needed to back it
up but i think that
having a more sort of simplified
handbook can be helpful for
for people of all ages but one point i
would want to make about what you were
just bringing up at the start
around um you know
around around this multi-generational
project
i would say that there's some really
interesting research that
shows that the most effective
communicators
at changing minds are
the young are the daughters of climate
change
deniers that or or people who believe
that
you know okay it's real but there's
nothing that we can do
um rather than hearing you know somebody
on television
lecture them um what what the research
finds
actually is that parents are being
swayed by their kids
their kids are pushing them around the
dinner table and saying what are you
doing about this i'm really frightened i
want something different
um so it turns out that that when we
reach kids we
actually do reach their parents we've
we've all
seen stories of a lifelong
typically republican elected official
who
had homophobic beliefs for a long time
and then
it turns out that you know they have an
lgbt
uh child in their family or nephew or
something like that
and they ultimately revisit their
beliefs and they
they come out with a different view and
and that's that's sort of good at the
maybe what we would call the retail
level but depending on everyone having
like a personal experience could be
difficult if that's what we're counting
on
i'm wondering how this would apply to
climate change where
to some degree does the cultural shift
need
the repercussions to be more real and
tangible to individuals before they may
be
fully willing to to consider they may
have been led astray on this issue
well the first thing i would just say is
that
people are already experiencing the
impacts of climate change
yeah and this is very very widespread
um and so i think
it's important to clearly explain how
something like what just happened in
texas
um may well be linked with a warming
destabilized climate
certainly the wildfires that people are
living with every summer in the pacific
northwest is
definitely linked to climate change um
certainly more ferocious
um summer storms are linked to warming
oceans
um so we need to be making those
arguments and it isn't like i just want
to be clear that that it's not like oh
we have to wait till things get really
bad and then people will understand this
is real things are bad
things are really bad um and we need to
make those arguments we need to make
those connections
um yeah so um and in terms of i mean i
guess your thoughts about the cultural
change that
that because with a lot of these things
it as we know it's not about hammering
facts necessarily
so i guess the other thing i would just
i would just emphasize this is just my
perspective i feel like some of your
questions are coming from
you are emphasizing what i would
describe as the hard deniers
right the kind of like the hardest to
reach
kind of fox news addicted
uh um you know it's all a chinese hoax
like really really
dug in right climate change deniers and
um i actually don't spend a ton of time
thinking about
how to reach the hardest to reach i
think that there's more productive work
to be done
in in what sometimes described as the
soft climate deniers or people who
actually don't deny the reality of
climate change at all
believe it is happening but what they
believe is that we're too
we're too far gone um it's human nature
and we're
all we're never gonna really care think
about the future um
kind of climate doomers more than
climate deniers
and i think we actually make a mistake
by over emphasizing reaching the hardest
to reach
most dug in most invested in that denial
mindset
while ignoring a much easier to reach
middle middle terrain of people who know
it's happening
but feel kind of hopeless about doing
anything about it
right that's interesting yeah if we if
we do a good job
if we do a good job of reaching the soft
deniers do the hard deniers even matter
as much
they matter much much less because in
fact what the polling shows is that a
majority
of americans know that climate change is
happening a lot of people think it's too
late
a lot of people think have bought the
idea that
you have to choose between good jobs and
acting on climate
um so there's a ton of work to be done
working with trade unions organizing
workers in different sectors
and um and and really
designing a future that people are
willing to fight for right that's what a
green new deal is about
um and breaking that's a false dichotomy
between job
job choosing between jobs and caring
about the environment that
i think is it's very productive how do
you suggest
approaching those who maybe are in that
that middle group where
they acknowledge that it's happening
they probably even acknowledge that
at least some part of it is because of
human activity if if not all
but they don't like what they believe to
be the solutions which might in their
minds include
we might not be able to have cars
anymore we'd be restricted on travel
we might have to keep our houses at 55
degrees in the you know that
they don't like what they believe the
lifestyle implications are
right and they believe that because
they've been lied to right they believe
that because there's been a very
systematic campaign
to um you know latch on to a throwaway
calm
joke that aoc made about banning cow
farts to claim that they're gonna
come seize your the cattle you know uh
um
and and and ban airlines forever things
like that
yeah um that's been a deliberate
campaign to scare people
um and so uh you know i
you know i think a a lot of these
arguments are not going to be won with
arguments they're going to be
one with facts they're going to be one
with with with people's lived
experiences and this is where i think
that it's useful
to think about some of fdr's strategies
in rolling out the original new deal
right the green new deal is
is modeled um after
and you know it's not it's not an
imitation it's also
it's also a corrective and lots of
ways and problems with the original new
deal but it's inspired by the original
new deal
in this scale in the mobilization in the
idea that we need a mission right
the original new deal was not a narrow
poverty alleviation program in the
middle of the great depression
it was a new governing framework that
affected every aspect of life right it
was dozens and dozens of policies
and that's the kind of ambition that we
need in the face of a crisis that
touches
every part of our lives right the reason
we get overwhelmed in the face of the
climate crisis
is because we know that it isn't going
to be solved by
you know changing our light bulbs like
we were told for a couple of decades
right i mean it it affects every aspect
of our lives and we've
never had a policy framework on the
scale of the crisis that we face
um so coming back to fdr
he was very smart um in in where he
cited a new deal projects like if you
map
where fdr planted
uh ccc projects for instance the
civilian conservation corps which is
responsible for around 800 state parks
planted
more than 2 billion trees employed
around 3 million young people
he deliberately cited those ccc camps
in the parts of the country that voted
against him and if you look at the
election results in 1936
he flipped many of those red rural areas
blue um and he and they didn't do it
with
arguments they did it with you know
backs on the ground
they did it with the this is services
that are
improving your community improving daily
life
creating jobs and people saw it
and they liked it and they wanted more
and so i think that this
is this should be a challenge for
the democrats you know they have lost
rural america
and we can't write off rural america
we need to invest and it isn't going to
be about
having the perfect argument and the
perfect messaging
it's going to be about what is this huge
green infrastructure program going to
look like who's going to benefit from it
how how is that going to be messaged
once it's being rolled out
um and that is way more important than
some abstract debate that we could have
about no no no it's not going to kill
jobs no
show people the jobs change people's
daily lives for the better
yeah along those lines i mean i'd love
to kind of wrap our conversation talking
legislatively we know joe biden
does not support the green new deal but
took many elements from it in putting
together
what what his proposal was before he was
elected and of course
we will now see if after this coveted
relief bill is done
whether that is very high on the list of
priorities and sort of what happens
do you think that if it if it doesn't
happen during these two years during
which democrats know they control the
house senate and white house
that it really becomes a question mark
as to if and when it happens i mean do
you think it's urgent that it be done
not just from the scientific standpoint
where obviously it's urgent
but politically as well yeah
it's urgent on both fronts right this is
our window we are now
in what we call the decade of the green
new deal right um
and and frankly i don't really care
about the branding of it you know you
want to call it buildback better i don't
care
what matters is that it's guided by
science and justice
um and and and as long as those core
principles are there
uh that we are staying within our carbon
budget of keeping temperature warming
below 1.5 degrees celsius doing
everything we possibly can
and i don't care what you call it you
know if 40
uh of of the green infrastructure is
actually going to be for frontline
communities of color
uh based on core environmental justice
principles i don't care what you call it
right because you're taking the core
ideas behind
uh the green new deal and behind the
just transition i mean the truth is
these ideas have gone by
many names over the years you know when
i wrote this changes everything i
started it with a quote from a bolivian
climate change negotiator who called for
a martial plan for planet earth
that's what they called it in 2009. you
know uh we've called it the leap
in canada i don't care what you call it
i care what we do
and we have two years you're absolutely
right we have two years to convince
people um with their lived experience
not convince people on television
convince people with their lived
experience and communicating the ideas
and the reality behind these policies
um because we just can't lose any more
time we have lost
decades talking and not acting yep
scientifically environmentally and
and politically urgent i think uh we we
would certainly agree
the book is how to change everything and
uh naomi klein the book's author is
senior correspondent for the intercept
so great having you on today
thank you it's been a pleasure take care
bye david